[Musique]
[Rires]
oh vous voyez vu à cette altitude tous
ces gens agglomérés dans ces bâtisses
mais il ya plus de cheminée moi de mon
temps avec les rênes
on y voyait plus clair envoyé des
cheminées on voyait de la verdure plat
on voit plus rien du tout alors je
descendais un peu que je voyais
j'arrive plus à percevoir les enfants
ils sont dans toutes ces grandes
bâtisses à l'épaule comme je les plains
et pourtant ces temps modernes ça
quelque chose de bien
fini mon grand traîneau avec mes rennes
celico maintenant père noël la
visibilité n'est pas fameux trou où les
villes jumelles
oh non merci commandant et mon oeil
magique et les étoiles
[Musique]
autrefois sam était beaucoup plus facile
il y avait beaucoup moins d'enfants est
beaucoup moins de jouer tandis que
maintenant avec le poids de mes anges en
aep la mode
[Musique]
je me demande comment j'y arriverai il
ya tellement de petits enfants
aujourd'hui et tranquilliser 1
oui on ne rappe toulouse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]